hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and
today we're going to be talking about
games which is a topic we've talked
about before we've talked about game
theory over and over again
also just the design of games is
something we once talked about with
frank lance who was a game designer so
today we're going to dive into the
philosophy of games what could be a more
mindscape-y topic than that because
games are an interesting thing when you
think about it i mean we set up these
struggles for ourselves right these
goals that it takes effort to reach and
we do this intentionally why in the
world do we do that whether it's playing
solitaire or playing basketball or
whatever sometimes we play games against
other people but often we just do it
against ourselves to sort of reach a
kind of goal so today's guest is t
nguyen who is a philosopher at the
university of utah who's thought a lot
about games and he has a theory of what
games are a philosophy one might even
say of what games are and the theory is
that games are a form of art which many
people have said but the form of art
isn't just you know visuals or even
stories it's agency in his point of view
so by playing different games what we're
doing is giving ourselves different
capacities right in different kinds of
games we're allowed to do different
things and those capacities are fairly
well defined usually and then we have
fairly well defined goals about winning
the game and by doing different games
we're taking on different kinds of
agency different choices we can make
different strategies we can deploy etc
so games are agency as art in teas uh
formulation and there's a lot about that
that sort of extends a little bit so one
of the great things about this podcast
episode is it will be one of those that
escalated quickly kinds of episodes so
we talk about what a game is the
importance of points and clarity of
criteria for success in the game right
that's one of the good things about the
artificiality of games you know when
you've won or lost unlike life
but the point is that that
knowledge that clarity of knowing when
you've won or lost
is very seductive outside the context of
a formal game it's very suctive in life
so t has developed this understanding to
study things like echo chambers and cult
leaders occult is in many ways like an
echo chamber in both cases it's not just
a filter bubble where you prevent
information you don't want from getting
in but it's like a strategy for
preemptively undermining claims from
outsiders that the cult leader or the
echo chamber doesn't want you to believe
in right you give people ways to
discount outside information and one of
the reasons why cults and echo chambers
are so seductive that they bring clarity
to values and moral reasoning
maybe a little bit too much clarity they
make it too easy they make things cut
and dried in a way that the world itself
is often not so cut and dried so he has
a whole understanding of why we're so
seduced by conspiracy theories by cult
leaders by echo chambers and how it
relates to this seductiveness of clarity
that we get from thinking about
games and points right we get points we
get likes on our tweets we get steps on
our fitbit this engages our brains for
interesting evolutionary reasons and
that feature of human psychology can be
gamed if you like by the leaders of
cults or echo chambers or whatever so
it's a fascinating conversation that
goes all sorts of places
let me take this opportunity to give you
the occasional reminder we have a web
page for mindscape
preposterousuniverse.compodcast
where you get not only show notes and
links for all the shows we do but
there's also complete transcripts of all
the shows and those transcripts are paid
for by supporters on patreon and you can
become a supporter on patreon
patreon.com
sean m carroll joined up for a tiny fee
you will get not only
the warm feeling that it comes from
supporting the podcast but also access
to ad-free versions of the show and of
course the ability to ask questions for
the monthly ask me anything episodes so
it's a great community we'd love to see
you there if that's your thing if you're
not that is also fine we love that
you're just listening to the podcast
from whatever modality you choose to do
that so with that let's go
[Music]
welcome to the mindscape podcast
thank you uh i am slowly caffeinating
good as i get over the there's a there's
a there's a morning experience
especially the zoom era i realize now
like
there aren't these transitional moments
where you used to have these
transitional moments
but right now like this this era is more
like
run downstairs make coffee now you're on
a podcast so we'll expect that you we
become more and more clear and
insightful as the podcast goes on that's
yeah that's very that's very common or
i'll just get worse right and i guess
actually i wasn't even going to mention
this but you know since you know you
mentioned the whole caffeination thing
um
before you were a philosophy professor
you were a food writer and you know
maybe you must have some potted
explanation of how that phase transition
came about because that's not very
common
oh yeah no so interestingly
i got the job as a food writer while i
was a graduate student um i got it
because i was obsessed with food i was
on this old
before yelp there was this forum called
chow hound oh people would
yeah so i
uh
i survived grad school partially by
exploring la and looking for things like
fish tacos
and
uh i would drunk post a lot of weird
stuff on show hound and apparently my
drunk posts were sufficiently good
that the ellie james food editor
spontaneously offered me a job i just
got a call after a drunk post um you
were discovering that a typical
hollywood story
yeah i was discovered drunk posting on
chat hound about like chicken and
waffles um
and then i had to make this decision
about
where what to do
like at some point you have this
food writing career that's taking off
and you have this graduate school career
then you have a job an academic job i've
got this academic job in utah and i
couldn't take the food writing job with
me so i had to make a decision
and basically in the end the decision
came down to
for one thing uh the other times it's
just firing people left and right
newspapers are dying and the other thing
was
after about five years food writing just
restaurant reviewing starts to be like a
little like oh my god
i have to say i have to say that
something is delicious a new way so i
promised myself if i went
to academia the academic path i would
still do something about like weird
aesthetics this is actually part of the
reason i ended up in the games project i
was like it was for me writing about
games is like writing about food you're
like
talking about things that
are amazing that the kind of like over
culture hasn't really figured out how to
appreciate right and you're you get you
get are allowed to talk about these fun
things in an academic way and get credit
for it yeah
the the games project was it i did it in
the way i wanted to do it which was like
uh
with the guard rails off and that was
something that like
that's that's the reason i was okay with
leaving food writing behind that's a
remarkably coherent story i guess that's
what i should expect from a philosopher
it's not just a random uh event so
that's good okay so um
a lot to talk about here so let's get
right into i'm gonna start with actually
a hard question i usually like to start
with some softballs i guess the food
writing was a softball question so
here's the hard one
um
i was at a panel discussion many years
ago full of theoretical physicists and
one of them was pushing the line that
the universe itself should be thought of
as a computer
and one of the other panelists said what
i think is the right thing which is well
is there anything that is not a computer
and he's a little stymied i think he not
you know had that one before so
that's now my question about games and
thinking about things about games you
know sure there are certain things that
we readily identify as games but it
seems like the category might almost be
too large how do you think about what is
a game and what is not a game
this is
a love this is a beautiful question um
so
you know
the the notion of a game is really
disputed in philosophy like it's very
storied like i mean
in philosophy it's a particularly famous
concept because when when wittgenstein
was like no you can't define concepts
his example of an undefined wall concept
was a game
so what really helps me is
this book this amazing book
uh from burner suits called the
grasshopper which is an attempt to
define games which actually takes itself
as a response to a victory and also like
secretly like about the meaning of life
and the relationship between games and
meaning of life
so he gives a definition of game that i
find incredibly useful
um
there's a short version of the long
version but the short version is
to play a game
is to voluntarily take on unnecessary
obstacles
for the sake of making possible the
experience of struggling against them
right so
his notion of a game is super specific
uh it's quite broad
right so it's any case where you take on
obstacles voluntarily partially for the
sake of the struggle itself so this will
include video games board games sports
right
other activities
that
m that
other people don't play as games you
could play as a game so he talks about
how someone like could take up a job as
a game right to do it for the sake of
the obstacles but not everything turns
out to be a game so
in his definition
um
when he when he expands the definition
part of the idea of the game is that
the
the goal of the game is partially
constituted by obedience to certain
restrictions yep so
wait a way to put that is
if you
simply move a ball through a basket that
doesn't count as making a basket in
basketball right because i mean imagine
you do it with a step ladder right
or you you use like some kind of like
grappling hook right so it has to be i
mean in basketball it doesn't count as
making a basket unless you
threw it from the ground just using your
hands and your feet and in some context
unless there was opposition
um right so what it is to make a basket
is to do it under these constraints what
it is to run a marathon is not just
across the finish line but to cross it
obeying the constraints
of
not using a taxi or not taking a lift or
a scooter right and actually that's a
great kind of definition because it
really sort of focuses us right in on
the specificity of the constraints which
are going to become
important later right like the
constraints are very very well set out
right yeah no it's and so i mean i i
think this book is one of the best books
of philosophy written it like i'll
change my i spent like 10 years of my
life working out the implications of
this book but it's i mean and he has
this lovely he's like look if you're
trying to get to the top of a mountain
to get some rare drug that's only there
you're not playing a game you're just
trying to get to the top of the mountain
if you're trying to climb the mountain
as a mountain climber
then
certain restrictions are part of what
you're doing so like the medical
seeker is not a game player yeah and the
mountain climber is and one way you can
tell is if someone goes by in a
helicopter and says hey you want to ride
right
medical climbers of course give me a
cancer drug and the other person's like
of course not what do you think i'm
doing
so this is probably that's exactly it
probably not
yeah so this is probably not um
your central focus but
saying that also immediately raises the
question of why in the world would
anyone ever play games like you're
saying that we invent struggles and then
subject ourselves to them isn't life
struggle enough
i know it's so
suit has this
this is actually part of the story i
feel like i'm filling out from suits in
my book um
so suits argues that so one way to put
it is that um it must be the so the the
philosopher's term for this is
autotellic some activities to be
autotelic is to be worth
it's worth engaging the activity for the
sake of the engagement and the doing
rather than the product so part of what
you get from suits is this view that
some activities
some activities we do because we want
the [ __ ] that comes out the other end
and some activities we do because it's
good to do the activity and so
the existence of games
forces you to accept that certain
activities are worth doing for their own
sake
and
yeah i guess there's like probably some
huge evolutionary slash psychological
sociological set of reasons why we find
that fulfilling personally but again
that's probably not
what your focus is i guess it is what my
focus on this is the center of what the
book is okay good sorry
[Laughter]
well
go ahead yeah elaborate on how that is
so i mean
so it's not there are lots of different
reasons so one problem i found with a
lot of early accounts of games is a lot
of early accounts of games
try to fix a particular value for all
games like all games are for freedom or
all games for education and suits very
cleverly just says no no it has to be
whatever the value is
the obstacles have to be part of an
essential part of it and there are lots
of things you could do it for you could
do it for exercise you could do it for
all kinds of one of my
one of the things that i'm most focused
on
is the aesthetic experience of struggle
that some struggles are beautiful some
struggles are satisfying and what games
do is
they let you
tweak the activity to maximize that
satisfaction so um
one way to put it
is that hey let me put it in the less
philosophical and then the more
philosophical way the less philosophical
way is like
in doing activities you get these like
regular practical activities you get
these moments of intense gorgeous
epiphany i mean you do physics i do
philosophy you'll do this thing where
like you're working on a problem and
there's this one moment
so it took you years you're like oh my
god i get it that's ecstatic
and i feel like things like chess
are
kind of like tuned to like maximize that
moment you get more and more of those
moments like in my normal life moving
around the world i get to feel graceful
like once a week but rock climbing like
it just
it tunes you into the part of the
activity that has that feeling and when
you rock climb like rock climbing is
constantly it's built to constantly call
out of you like that incredible
experience of like delicate graceful
perfect emotion
so that's the more philosophical way to
say it is
um
our abilities and the world don't fit
very well in real life like most of the
challenges are too big yeah or too
boring and little for us
and in games we get to like
modify the world of the game and the
abilities we're allowed in the game
until they fit just right and games are
like
games have been carefully manicured by
us
so that they are a place where for once
in our lives
we have exactly and just barely the
ability to do it and it's perfect that
makes actually a lot of sense and i
hadn't thought about this but i just did
a podcast with nigel goldenfeld who was
a physicist and we talked about phase
transitions you know like liquid
ice liquid water freezing to ice and
things like that and how there are
certain critical scale-free phenomena at
phase transitions if you tune yourself
to be right there and just stay at the
transition maybe like the perfect game
is at that precisely tuned critical
point where it's like there's little
challenges but you can get them there's
big challenges you can get them too
maybe you're not sure right
no that that that's exactly also
from the other side of the stuff i work
on
i think i think that a lot of
conspiracy theories
are tuned
to give you the exact same pleasure like
um and i think that i'm not the only one
that's noticed that there's something
like very game-like about right q and
unlock it's like so
in those cases i think what you're
seeing is another case where someone has
like
changed the nature of the world
apparently to make it tractable um like
and i think it's really important that
like
this is like we can we can talk more
about this but i think it's really
important that like
for those of us who live in this in the
sci in
the world of science um the world is
vastly beyond our understanding right
like you can't like scientists are
hyper-specialized no one's understanding
everything at some point you realize
that you have to just trust tons of
stuff that you have no
ability to grapple with
and conspiracy theories are often like
don't be sheep don't trust other people
here is a vision of the world where you
can contain the world
in you you can explain all of it with
this one powerful explanation and i
think like it it is a game like pleasure
but exported to a place where it's
dangerous no i mean that's it's that's a
very important point and in a completely
different realm uh you know sometimes i
engage in discussions between theists
and naturalists on the naturalist side
and there's a there's a remarkable
number of times when a theist will say
like how can anyone be a naturalist
they're constantly saying that they
don't know the answer to this question
or that question and i give the answer
to all these questions and you know
that's that's clearly compelling right
to be able to sort of
control that that potentially vast
sphere in a very simple system yeah i
mean that there's this it's funny
saying things like this because like a
philosopher is supposed to be like the
center at the center of the ideal of
intellectual autonomy like think for
yourself um and i think
now i find myself in places being like
no forget that idea like find a find a
more minimal fallback version of that
ideal because that's impossible i mean
a lot i got the clearest version of this
from this amazing book this philosophy
recent philosophy about one of my
favorites by elijah milgram
um
called the great endarkenment
and it's a book about what knowledge
there's a small part of philosophy
that's working on this problem now of
like what knowledge must be like not as
an individual quest but given the fact
that the world is so hyper-specialized
that no one can know more than a tiny
amount of it and part of the way he puts
it is
the ideal of intellectual autonomy was
what drove the great enlightenment and
it doomed itself because it created all
the amount all the science that made it
impossible
to be intellectually autonomous and i
think if you if you still hold to the
old ideal of intellectual autonomy if
everyone can understand everything
what you get is being driven
to
anti-vaxxing and yeah
various conspiracy theories in which you
reject
trust in the sciences
what do best buy wayfair marco polo and
among us have in common
they trust lenode as an alternative to
the cost and complexity of the world's
largest public cloud providers lenode
makes cloud computing simple affordable
and accessible whether you're working on
a personal project or looking for
someone to manage your company's
infrastructure the node has the pricing
support security and scale you need with
lenod you get consistent and predictable
pricing across 11 global markets
24x7 by 365 human support rich
documentation and policies and controls
to strengthen your overall security
posture allowing you to grow at your own
pace
users consistently rank lenode as one of
the leading public cloud providers on
both g2 and trust radius find out why
visit lenode.com mindscape that's
l-i-n-o-d-e dot com slash mindscape and
start a free account today
yeah no i mean i i was gonna hope to get
to this later in the podcast but we
should just get there right now because
it's so uh very very important i've said
this in other podcasts i've done the
fact that
we're finite right that you know we have
bounded computational resources as my
previous guest stephen wolfram put it uh
it's a hugely underappreciated fact
about the reality of our existence in
the world and there were some
interesting examples that came up
recently
uh in mathematics where people you know
the professional mathematicians have
admitted sheepishly to the world
that a proof of a really important
mathematical theorem might be understood
by 10 people and the whole rest of the
community just has to trust it because
you're not going to spend a year
learning the proof and there was one
proof of a really famous theorem that
literally
only one guy understood and he's getting
old so a whole bunch of people had to
like have a project to you know re-write
the proof in a way that other people
could understand it and
and that whole process of dealing with
the fact that you need to trust some
things while you shouldn't trust
everything that's a tricky thing that is
probably under theorized right i mean
this is this for the part of me that
doesn't do philosophy of art this is
the exact thing you described is what
i'm spending my life on i think like
a lot of the work i've done outside of
games is on the notion of trust and
how we trust and how we manage trust and
i think
there's an old
there's an old ideal and philosophy
which i think you still see influencing
has its influencing fingers all over the
land intellectual landscape and that's
the ideal that
you should be able to understand
every single thing you believe
to some degree and i think the basic i
mean
the place where we've arrived at is
at best if you wrote your entire life to
it you can understand one one millionth
of
the human landscape of knowledge
and this i mean
so
a lot of my work is what other people
think of as pessimistic and i think it
was just realist and
level one you can't understand
everything else level two
you don't even have the capacity in and
of yours in yourself to pick the right
experts to trust yeah right like like so
i'm a philosopher i have a phd in
philosophy i have a lot of education
if you gave me a good a real
statistician and a fake one
i couldn't like and they just like had
math on a wall yeah i don't have the
mathematical skills to tell the
difference between a good statistical
paper and one that gives a bad result
right um i don't have that in myself so
what you get is actually this
incredibly iterated and very fractal
chain of trust
right and a lot of it runs through like
i i mean literally i trust this result
because it came from someone who's at
princeton university like
the
those kind of stat institutional
statuses end up as like the kind of
vital proxies and heuristics we have to
use and i think you're right people have
radically underestimated the place
that we've been left in and how much of
the modern intellectual [ __ ] show yeah
comes from different
vulnerabilities caused by this position
because people i mean i know plenty of
people are like oh these [ __ ]
anti-vaxxers anti-massacres think for
yourself look at the science evaluate
the science and what you have to say is
like you you like i can't evaluate that
science
well but it's that's a
it's great that you say that because
it's so hard for people to admit i had
julia galif on the podcast talking about
rationality and trying to be rational
and we we discussed this issue of you
know when you're not an expert in a
field how do you separate the experts
from the non-experts and so she went as
as julia does she went on twitter and
sort of talked about her own thoughts
out loud and you know talked about these
different social cues right like how
much of a you know where is the person
who else says they're good and
everything and instantly like people
flooded with comments saying but that's
not rational you're just you know not
actually evaluating the evidence and
she's like how could i possibly evaluate
the evidence as an expert in every field
but i also want to point what's so
important is
so
a lot of the times we're doing this
we're saying something like oh you
should look at the people that are
legitimated
in a certain institutional structure
which involves a background trust in
those institutions
and i think like
there's this vision or for a lot of us
like
what like when you look at like
anti-vaxxing
anti-masking anti whatever climate
change denialist space what we want to
say is something like oh those people
are totally irrational but i think
what you have to think instead is
they have an entirely different basic
framework of trust
for a different set of institutions
and the degree of rationality there
depends on the degree to which we can
justify our trust in our institutions
and that's a really really complicated
matter and it's not like the
authoritative institutions are always
right
we know right there are plenty of
historical cases where they are
corrupted right yeah
so that's that's where the actual
intellectual
like
that's where the actual action is
happening right like
how are people picking the right set of
institutions to put their trust in
because they can't evaluate things for
themselves well and it's hard to be you
know
against conspiracy theories as a blanket
statement because sometimes there are
conspiracies right this is this is the
point that you get this is the point
this is one of the mistakes that drives
me the most wild like someone that wants
to say like oh conspiracy theories
are
blanket incorrect you're like no no
there are real conspiracies in the world
um and
you have to you have to make room for
the fact that
and there are i mean we have plenty of
historical examples where all the
institutions in a particular country
have become corrupted i have taken over
the news media are issuing false
statements that's a real thing that
happens right yeah it's
well uh
i kind of want to get back to games but
can we very very briefly just give the
solution to this problem
[ __ ] no
basically so i i think that
bounded rationality and limited
rational limitations are
the
primary intellectual fact
about our current era the most important
thing is to figure out
how to put the structures of trust
correctly
a lot of the problems we're seeing right
now when you're looking at the alt-right
and race conspiracy theories shouldn't
be thought of
as problems of like brute irrationality
or just like meaning or something this
is this is for readers are interested i
have a paper uh called echo chambers and
episomic bubbles that that that
gives you this argument in more detail
and that actually what's going on is
that a large segment of the population
has had their trust
subverted and undermined and directed
towards what we think of as like the
wrong institutions so
one of the results you're going to get
from this is that the way
back is to repair
trust that's been broken
the way back is not to wave the evidence
in people's faces right i think people
want to be like oh look climate change
and analysts just look at the evidence
here's the evidence but of course
they're not showing the evidence they're
showing
scientists that they trust who process
the evidence because
not even a climate change sign a
particular climate change scientist has
looked at all of the evidence for
climate it's all processed right um
and so if you just wave like look here's
the publication result or here's what
the fiscal model says and
someone that whose trust has been
systematically undermined in that set of
institutions to say no like i don't
accept that and it's it is i just want
to point out rational not to trust
evidence from sources that you distrust
sure right
so the way back is to repair
trust that's been undermined on a large
scale
in a massive public how do you do that
that sounds hard yeah
but i mean i think people have i mean
at least
what i can say now is i think people
have
need to get fixed on the right story the
wrong story is people we're not hearing
the other side the right story is
oh no trust has been systematically
systematically undermined yeah and just
to be uh you know clear that it's not
just sort of cartoonish conspiracy
theories or climate denial or whatever
like as you mentioned before the word
fractal you know this this sort of
dilemma happens at all levels like when
you're uh
i don't know when you're in a physics
department and they want to hire someone
who is outside your subfield and they
say no this person's work is really good
and someone else is no it's not
it can be very hard to adjudicate that
you know it's interesting because elijah
milken is great in darkness
the example he gives is an academic job
search exactly he runs exactly like it's
like i mean you don't he's like you
don't need to go to the world of like
non-expert experts in some like dramatic
way you just need to think about a dean
who's you know a neurobiologist trying
to adjudicate a hiring decision between
a business school and like a complete
department like
good luck with that you're supposed to
do that right
um
right uh but
oh you you said something super
interesting that i wanted to talk about
and then i it totally slipped my mind
deciding between physicists working in
different fields or yeah i don't know
but we'll get there don't worry it'll
come back up because i do
the word games is going to be in the
title of this episode so we did talk
more about games um right uh so you know
one of the things you mentioned is the
struggle right the the reason why we
like games is this feeling of of
uh conquering something or making
achievements against it and the other
you know the other is like there is a
reward for achieving a goal right like
the example that comes to mind for me
which is completely irrational and i
know it but
you know i have various very simple
trivial games on my iphone that i will
play when i'm waiting in line for
something or whatever and then once the
solitaire game that i play introduced
daily goals so like every morning it
gives you a different goal then now i
play that solitaire game a lot more
often because now i can get a daily goal
and i have no idea why it is that i
really care about getting that daily
goal
um
i mean
i
so i think we are the kind of creature
that's easily permeated by outside goals
right someone could just present a goal
to us and we can take it on and games
are actually not the only but the
clearest example
of
that phenomenon so
one thing so first of all a little
little side example not every game is
based on the fun
on the on the joy of winning so this is
really crucial to my account let me get
let me give you a little bit about the
here's a little bit of technical
argument
from
my game stuff
so i think there are two different
motivations you can play used to play a
game one is achievement play the other
striving play achievement play is trying
to
win a game for the value of the win
itself
striving play is temporarily getting
interested
in the win
for the sake of something in the
struggle right so so
in in
achievement play you play to win in
striving play you make yourself care
about winning temporarily for the joy of
the struggle right um but interestingly
for a lot of the kinds of joys of
struggle you really have to make
yourself want that win right you know
like the
the joy of like a good chess match or a
good rock climb for me it's like no you
have to you have to be fully in it fully
absorbed in it otherwise it's not
otherwise you're not processing all the
possibilities right all that stuff
but
you might immediately think
i mean some people think no no there's
no such thing as driving play that's
weird the only thing that makes a sense
an achievement play so here are two
arguments that striving play exists one
is that sometimes even we try to win
hard in the short term we don't try to
make ourselves more able to win in the
long term so
this is a simple example this is real so
my wife and i play board games all the
time
a lot of the times
a lot of games so if a game involves
deceit and social manipulation i'm going
to win
if a game involves
geometric manipulation she's going to
win she's a chemist like her 3d mind is
amazing sometimes we find a game that
we're perfectly matched at and it's
awesome
and then at night i will find a strategy
guide
and if the point of playing a game was
to win there's only one thing i should
do right read the strategy guide yeah
win the game win the game everybody he's
never going to read strategy guy too
that's not kind of but i don't read the
strategy guide right and i think that
reveals i'm a striving player right
my goal is not to win otherwise i would
read the strategy guide i just have to
make myself want to win temporarily to
have this struggle but the fact that i'm
avoiding
gaining skill outside the game indicates
what i really care about is the quality
of the struggle and not winning i think
this is true for a lot of us here's
another example
this is why i want to talk this is where
i was headed um
so consider the category of what i want
to call stupid games so stupid game is a
game where one
the fun part is failing but two you have
to actually try to win to have that fun
twister
most drinking games the kids came with
telephone right so if you play twister
and you intentionally fall
that's not funny
it is only funny because it's a failure
it's only a failure if you're trying to
win but i just want to note that our
life is permeated by all these silly
stupid social games
that we take on and we try to win at but
the whole point is that it's
hysterically funny when we lose
i mean think about the structure of most
drinking games the point of most
drinking games is to try to do some dumb
thing and then fail
and then everyone laughs
let me see i mean
you you paint a convincing picture that
there are striving games um but now i
want to turn it around and say are there
achievement games i mean is it all just
about the struggle even within the video
game world where you can often
have a setting where you're playing on
easy mode or regular mode or hard mode
and people will naturally tune
themselves to the mode where
they can potentially succeed but it's
hard right so one thing i should say is
that achievement plans driving play are
motivational states in players
not in games so you can you can have one
achievement player in chess and another
striving player and chess or someone
that has both motives um
so i think there are
there's plenty of variation the place
where you're most likely to see
achievement play is high-end play
professional play um people if someone's
just like well i'm not i just want
better mileage for my marathons like
it's it's miserable but i want it
right um
here's here's an easy case uh
professional poker players yeah
right
like if
money is tied to the win and their main
reason to play is money
um i actually doubt that they're ver
i think there are relatively few
achievement players
pure
in social play
it's going to look really different in
professional play i think there are some
and what
what that will look like is someone that
is entirely obsessed with say
getting better and uninterested in
whether it's fun right but i think most
of us pay some attention
to
how fun it is how interesting it is
whether we enjoy the thing or not
especially if we conceive of it as a
hobby
although entertainment on the flip side
of that you know i i i'm a poker player
myself and i've had a couple poker
players on the podcast and one of the
interesting facts about poker is
because i try to play with people
sometimes who have never played and you
know teach me and whatever and one of
the moves they try to make sometimes is
to say well i want to learn but i don't
want to play for money so let's just
play for eminem's or whatever
and
there's nothing less interesting than
playing poker for no stakes right that
you know the stakes really make it
you know otherwise you just sort of like
bet incredible amounts and who cares so
there is something about those stakes
that is really important
yeah so i mean i'm not saying that i
think plenty of people play poker with
stakes for striving reasons um and there
are many cases where the threat of some
amount of loss
increases
the pleasure i mean yeah
for example
in climbing if you're climbing away
on on a top rope where you can't fall at
all it's totally different from when
you're climbing on lead and you're
facing a 20-foot fall and it could
hurt and like that degree of stake
changes the intensity of the experience
and it's really clear that like the most
intense absorbed and i'm 100 a striving
player here still is when there's some
stakes on because the stakes change the
experience one way to i mean one way to
identify the difference between striving
players and achievement players is
really like it's not going to be how
they play during the game because a lot
of striving players are going to try
just as hard to win and uh and like the
same kinds of intense experiences it's
going to be their
if you listen to their motivations
outside the game about game choice
and
um their reasons for continuing to play
a game so if you're an achievement
player
so
here's a reason you could have to stop
playing a game it wasn't fun for me
anymore yeah right
if you have if you say that then you
weren't an achievement player right if
you were doing well at a game
but you stopped because it wasn't fun
[Laughter]
um then
right and similarly i think a lot a lot
of people try really hard but they'll
also pick
so
i'm what's in the back of my mind is
there have been a set of exchanges in
philosophy between me and a couple of
peop other people tom harkin and part
gwen bradford and those are two people
whose life's work and philosophy is
built around the value of achievements
and perfecting yourself and they
especially tom harker has this very
strong like games are mostly for you
know developing your excellence and
um
being more perfect and that's what most
people play at this driving place stuff
is just this weird tiny thing that if
that's kind of and i'm like you know
like
look at so when i responded to them i
ended up quoting a lot of game reviewers
and i think like if you have like a
model like that then you should expect
people to play the hardest game they can
succeed at but you don't find that a lot
of the times people will be like well
that game's hard but it's boring
right this game is more interesting and
when you have i think the majority of
game play going on is striving play well
at least their theory made a falsifiable
prediction so that was that's really
good you know and you claim to have
falsified it but
it it it is an empirical matter but i
mean
look at game reviews right and maybe
that's really different when i think
people like tom harker really focus on
the on olympics and if you listen to
player talk at the olympics i think it
probably does lean achievement play but
if you look at what i've been looking at
which is like board game reviews and
video game reviews and people talking
about why they chose running instead of
you know lifting or vice versa that
stuff seems loaded with this kind of
talk of like what satisfies me what
makes me feel like relax what makes me
feel like perfectly like right it's it's
experiential talk
after hours of dedicated research
nothing feels better than the
satisfaction of finally finding the
information you've been looking for and
you can get that same incredible feeling
when you're able to find your next great
hire after a candidate search with
indeed if you're hiring you need indeed
indeed is a hiring partner that gets you
what you really want a short list of
quality candidates as fast as possible
because you can do it all attract
interview and hire all at the website at
indeed indeed partners with you on every
step of the hiring process so you can
find talent with the skills you need
through tools like indeed instant match
assessments and virtual interviews with
instant match as soon as you sponsor a
post you get a short list of quality
candidates whose resumes on indeed match
your job description and you can even
invite them to apply right away get
started right now with a 75 sponsored
job credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape indeed.com mindscape offer
valid through december 31st terms and
conditions apply need to hire you need
indeed
well and you've also made the case
beyond struggling and striving you you
like to think of games as art
and in particular art in the medium of
agency which is uh you know those are a
lot of big words and maybe i'll let you
uh gloss them a little bit in this
context
right so the the um
okay
so
um
i started this project out of annoyance
which is actually
where most of my philosophy projects
start i started the project
reading a bunch of books about why games
so a bunch of other people are defending
engage like oh games are important games
are art when you read this stuff what
you find often is
that people are talking about how games
tell good stories or have beautiful
graphics or have good characters or have
good scripts ways in which games are
like movies right which is a familiar
form of art so you find this a lot in
the history of art people say something
like oh my god
photographs must be a kind of art
because they can be like paintings and
then making photographs that look like
paintings instead of doing the special
thing that photographs can do and i was
really interested in the fact that
they're all these game these books about
games defending games and they never
talked about
choice skill difficulty
puzzles like all the stuff that seems
unique to me about games
so i was interested in developing theory
and there are other people who are i'm
not alone in this i in developing a
theory that talked about games in art
form that focused on their game-ness
like what's it's not saying that games
can't tell stories but what makes games
the distinctiveness yeah yeah
so
um i i remember reading
my favorite board game designer uh is
reiner kanitia he's just like german
board game genius people call him the
mozart of games he's like made like
hundreds of games they're all amazing um
not all but like just amazing ones just
flow from him like
i don't know
mozart milk
so from a cow just
um that was the worst
i'm sorry
but he said the most important
tool in his tool kit
is the point system
because the point system tells the
players what their motivations are
and he's some really interesting games
we can see him playing around with this
where like
one a lot of people build this kind of
game where you're collecting a bunch of
stuff and you just want to collect as
much as possible and here's a game where
oh you're collecting four different
colors by this complex system and your
scores whichever color you have the
least of
right
and that totally changes the way you go
about the game or
his scoring systems were like
or he he invented cooperative board
gaming where everyone scores together
right so the
the scoring system sets your motivation
to set who's on your side that's what
you're trying to do and i was like oh my
god that's so interesting and i haven't
seen i mean that kind of insight is all
over the game design space but i haven't
seen anyone in this like critical
literature talking about it so i ended
up trying to like give a
art theory based on that and it's that
what game designers do is not just
create environments and they don't just
tell stories they tell you who to be in
the game they in my language design an
agency which
mostly consists of
your abilities but also your goals
so they create the obstacles for you and
your abilities and goals together and
that's the actual art so the way i put
it in the book is that the artistic
medium of games is agency itself right
someone is telling you what you can do
and what you should do what you should
pursue
what your practical relationships are to
the world and each other
and that's the heart of game design
that's that that's what makes games
special they're sculpted experiences
of practicality and one of the interests
one of the things i think that's
interesting here is that this is a
radically different
art form
so in a lot of cases
i think when people want to talk about
the artistic qualities of a thing that
an artist made they want ones that stay
in the thing they want like qualities
are in the novel in the painting i think
what's interesting in games is
if games are sculpted practicality then
the beauty emerges in the practical
action so in other words when you play a
game it's not a game that's beautiful
it's you that's beautiful right like or
funny or awkward right like in twister
you're the you're the person that like
fell comically and everyone laughs at in
rock climbing like i'm the person that's
momentarily graceful or like in chess
like
the beauty is in your mind figuring out
right so it's like
the
game designers are creating situ are
creating environments that sculpt our
actions where the beauty is supposed to
show up not in the environment of the
game itself
but in our action i mean it can also
show up in the environment but like i
think a lot of the literature about
games he's been going around looking for
qualities that are in the game like oh
the graphics are beautiful the sound is
beautiful the story is beautiful and
they're not looking at how radically
different games are
and i think there are other things like
this that are also mostly neglected but
they're
but here here is it but the the thing
that makes games unique is that they're
sculpted action right well and the the
the coin of the realm in some sense when
you're playing the game like you say are
your choices your actions
and the great thing about the games or
anything maybe i shouldn't normalize it
as saying it's great but
they're very
circumscribed right like you're told
here are the possible actions and then
you you can take them at any time it's a
little bit it's way cleaner than the
real world in which the set of actions
is dauntingly infinite yeah that that's
i mean that is exactly
i mean so john dewey
one of the great american philosophers
of art said that
what art is is you're taking life
experiences and you're like
crystallizing the special unities and
harmonies in them and like accentuating
them right i think this is exactly right
like
life is this [ __ ] mess in which we
sometimes get these moments of clarity
and games are these circumscribed spaces
where
the actions in space have been
often like leaned down and clarified
so your actions
can fit perfect right they're clarified
not just because the items are
this is what's really important to me
they're not just clarified because the
actions you can perform have been
clarified it's because your values have
been clarified
um this is what makes and also i just
want to say in the background um
one of the reasons
i'm interested in this stuff is because
this is more stuff about human beings
and essentially bounded and limited
beings right like this is this is how
bounded and limited beings
make things that make them feel
temporarily okay
right
like
spaces where we don't feel too little
for this vast world but like look
um i mean this is not
this is actually something i'd say in
the book that gay like the real world's
this exhibitional hellscape of like too
many values and games are this like
temporary bomb where you like the world
makes [ __ ] sense and it's like nice
for a little bit but yeah so in our life
there are too many values there are too
many things to find important and the
values are hard
to
apply i mean so i'm trying to be a
parent i want to be a good parent
i'm putting my kid to bed and he has you
know he's a toddler he rips off his
diaper and throws around and like he's
pretending to do some story where he's
battling his diaper and i'm like
i could be succeeding in creating you
know raising a creative artist
or i could be totally failing to create
a disciplined normal human being i don't
know
right but
in games the game tells you exactly what
to do tells you exactly how to measure
it tells you exactly how well you're
doing and
it tells you exactly what everyone wants
too so for a moment
you can have total value clarity and
that's beautiful yeah we all agree on
what the points are that is a crucial
part of playing the games and you know
the clarity of values clearly very very
important but i don't want to quite uh
leave the clarity of possible actions
like let's say a word about that because
i know that
sometimes on the podcast talk about
artificial intelligence and you know
there's these great successes with
playing go and playing chess and i
always make the point well
sure those are literally the
most
obvious places where a computer should
be able to kick our ass because the
rules are so well defined and some
people are like no no go is very very
complicated but it's nowhere near as
complicated as the real world in some
sense right i mean
part of the reason i don't i mean
i i totally know what you're talking
about but there's a theoretical reason
i'm not talking about it and the reason
is that i'm trying to give so most
theories and games tend to focus on
either sport or video games and i'm
trying to give like a pan game theory
yeah and i think the thing you're
talking about is definitely true of
board games like poker is incredibly
clear case super limited actions but
it's not clear in every case so let me
give you a few examples
so
a lot of adventure sports
so survival like
here's i mean i use this example books
like someone you can be dropped into
alaska with nothing but a knife to fight
your way out that counts as a game if
you're doing it for game like reasons
yeah there's no limitation on your
affordances right right um you can
uh
the
the
another really interesting case is
tabletop role-playing
because tabletop role-playing has a few
rules that like set your motivations and
there are a few there are a few rules
for how you decide things but when
you're trying to figure out how to
navigate this environment the world is
your oyster like you basically can
invent stuff and part of what's going on
there is a game master that can like
come up with the world's response so i
think that like the vision
of games as having delimited clear
actions
is true of board games and card games is
partially true of video games although
there are some where the emergent space
of possible actions is becoming richer
as the number of actions get richer it
is not true of a lot of
physical games and real world games and
more narrative imagination games like
tabletop role playing which don't have
that character at all okay no that's a
very good point but the um even those
games do share this clarity of values we
all have the same goals and now right uh
with that philosophical point in mind
you know this this is what leaks back to
the previous discussion about um echo
chambers and so forth uh and and maybe
this is where gamification comes in that
games are fun and we all agree on the
points and so wouldn't it be great if
the whole rest of our lives were like
that and we assigned points to
everything and everyone can come up with
their favorite examples of how that
works
yeah
yeah no this is
so
so at the um
so the standard view
kind of in the industry is that games
are great so gamification is great right
if you if you believe in games then you
should believe we should gamify work
gamify education gamify fitness make it
all more like a game and i actually
think
if you believe all the stuff i've told
you and you understand why games are
great
then
you see that gamification is a [ __ ]
existential horror yeah because games
are a temporary artificial clarity
and they're fine because they're
temporary right game values are hyper
crisped up
and that's fine if you
put away those values at the end but
when you gamify something like education
or communication
then you're
forcing a singular
clarified value system
on a real world activity so i have a
paper about twitter and i'm working on
new stuff about like how this happens in
with grades and things like this but
notice the difference and fitbit
fitbit's a really important exam but
notice one difference
if you decide to play games what that
looks like is you get to pick from a
vast menu of different games
and try them on temporarily and then
reflect on whether they were fun or not
if you're engaged in twitter
there are not a lot of other choices for
social media social discourse and
there's if you let yourself be gamified
by it and be captured by those points
there's no ability to change systems set
those points aside and what what you're
getting is instead like this
you're squashing the values that a lot
so people normally communicate with a
large a wide variety of pluralistic
values and people like me this is really
important it's really important that
people do bring different communicative
values to the
the social ecosystem but
something like
twitter's gamification
squashes those values yeah and gets
everyone in so far as they're motivated
to be motivated in the same direction to
it so the very thing that's like fun and
sexy
in games
it's okay because they're limited that
everyone pursues the same point and a
really simple one when you export it
like to communication it like squashes
one of the most important things about a
vibrant social political community
so i don't think it's good i've had a
lot more examples
well there's lots of examples i mean you
know just the idea that there's a number
out there we can maximize is a seductive
one but a dangerous one my one of my
favorite examples again as academics uh
i used to be at the university of
chicago which obviously has always been
academically super duper strong but back
in the day
uh it wasn't
like the place you applied if you were
interested in harvard or stanford or
princeton like it was less well
um so it
suddenly you know there was a strategy
that they undertook at the university of
chicago because they were being hurt in
the u.s news rankings
and they were being hurt because the
only people who applied to the
university of chicago were the ones who
really wanted to go there
and you are rewarded in the us news
rankings by having a high selectivity
right by rejecting most of the people
who apply so they intentionally
encouraged people to apply
knowing they would reject them because
it increased their selectivity and they
left up in the rankings that's an
example of maybe the goal perverting the
original aspiration
so this is
by the way if you're interested in the
stuff the best document i know about it
is this book engines of anxiety by wendy
esplant and michael souter which i just
recommend to everybody it's a book about
their sociologist it's a 10 year
empirical study about what happens to
the
law school culture and student culture
when the youth news and world report
starts ranking law schools and they have
data from before and after and
basically they say
they chart a bunch of stuff like what
you're talking about about people gaming
the rankings but i think there's
something even more devastating which is
so one of the things i point out is that
different law schools used to follow
different missions before the rankings
yeah but if the mission is skewed to the
ranking at all
then you drop in the rankings force
everyone to pursue the same values it's
the same thought again it drives value
plurality out of the system that's bad i
mean that's definitely bad when you have
people gaming it fakely like the example
you're talking about which they talk
about stuff like that too but even if
it's all like kind of like not just
gaming the algorithm but genuinely
trying to up the targets you're still
so like having a social justice mission
doesn't get counted in the us news and
world report yeah so if you spend
resources on that
you're gonna get [ __ ] um but the most
interesting thing to me this is actually
this is the center of the stuff i'm
working on right now
the
esplanade insider say that um
before the rankings prospective law
students
used to
talk about what different law schools
valued
and talk about their own values and
decide what their values were
and to pick which school to go to but
that happens because there's a
presentation of a plurality of values
now they say
99 of the students just assume their
goal is to get in the best school right
where the best school is set by the
ranking so they don't go through the
process of value self-deliberation so
i say this a little bit
at the end of the book but i i um this
is basically the next book i'm working
on
um the way i want to put it these days
is i think that in these cases you end
up outsourcing your values
you end up letting somebody else perform
value deliberations for you and the and
what goes into those values are often
very much based in what's in the
interest of large-scale institutions and
the kind of information management
systems that large-scale information
like they need [ __ ] i mean we can talk
about there's a huge amount of stuff to
talk about here if you want but like
large-scale institutions need things
that can be input in a standardized way
into a spreadsheet yeah
and so any
value systems they emit are going to be
subject to those kinds of interests and
are going to be standardized across
a vast institution so in a lot of these
cases i think what we're doing is we're
like
uptaking values that aren't specialized
to us
but
are set
by institutions to be the kind of things
that institutions can track and like i
mean this is one example i think fitbit
is another example right you could have
a lot of values in your life
with
exercise
i mean i'm not saying that every use of
fitbit is bad
but
what you're doing when you're letting
fitbit motivate you is that you're
letting a specific target that's been
set because it's the kind of thing that
can be measured easily by a watch
yeah dominate
your goal system
well the line that i read from you uh
that i'm going to paraphrase that made
it very vivid to me was we shouldn't
worry about games creating serial
killers we should worry about them
creating wall street bankers
yeah i know the point the point there is
just that
people worry a lot about games creating
violence and there's actually a lot of
data that mostly they don't um and i
think part of that is that the violence
in games is fictional
and we have a lot of information that
people are mostly capable of screening
off fictions the thing that i'm really
worried about is people becoming used to
the idea
that
the goal is some simple quantified thing
that people share and what we're
supposed to do
is
do everything in our power to up that
simple measure
and one thing to note that's not
fictional no if you get points in a game
and you be like
here's one way to put it if we're
playing a shooter and i headshot you in
the shooter the fact that i killed you
is fictional the fact that i beat you
is not fictional right that's real
and the worry is that that doesn't have
the fictional screen
and so
people who leave games
the bad side of things might be that
they
keep looking for systems that offer them
clear quantified views of success and
then they'll enter into worlds and
pursue those quantities
without reservation without limitation
without balancing which is what you're
allowed to do in a game
well and we think even money even
more broadly in life we tend to say that
clarity is a virtue right like we're
clear about things like we know what's
going on uh but one of the very
interesting things about you know how
you've written about these things is
that you know the dark side of clarity
right the the fact that
clarity when we reach clarity that's
when we stop thinking and so you know
these this search for very very
simplistic conspiratorial ways of
looking about the at the world are uh
seductive for exactly that reason
because it gives us that clarity yeah no
this is so
one way to put it is that
one one way to put it centering the game
stuff
is that
games are an artificial clarity
it's lovely we love it it feels great
but
it's important when we leave games to
realize that that's an artificiality
and
that we have to
spend much of the rest of our lives
living in unclarity and refusing that
will tempt you into assist into a system
of belief that's like oh the more money
in my life the better money equals
success
um
another way to put it
this is one of the this is
so
this is one of the worries i've been
developing so look
looking
at both the literature on how
quantified values work in bureaucracy
and looking at the literature on
conspiracy theories one of the things i
struck by in both
is the way in which in all these
accounts
people seem to
when things feel clear they stop
thinking
and so i the
i ended up writing this paper that
you're referencing the selections of
clarity and
this is again about bounded rationality
and limited rationality right so here's
the theory we're limited beings we can't
think about everything we need to know
when to cut off our
investigations right we need to manage
our efforts
it looks like from the empirical
literature that the way that many of us
do this is that at the moment we use a
heuristic and the heuristic is if things
feel clear we're done
right
and so my suspicion is if we're using
that heuristic then we should expect
malicious actors to try to game that
heuristic and present us with things
that feel clear
um where that feeling of clarity has
been amped up and i think like so
conspiracy theories are one example this
kind of like bureaucratic metrified
language where everything that you do
has a clear measure of success like
that's another version of this
um
and one way i think about it is like
it's not that clarity is always bad like
there is sure when when you have
intellectual success you do have this
feeling of clarity my worries the
feeling of clarity actually comes apart
from real understanding
and that outside actors can game it i
mean another way to put it is i think
in the course of evolution in an earlier
stage in evolution it made perfect sense
for us
to pursue sugar and fat because you know
calories are scarce
it's hard to get enough fat just
use as much of that [ __ ] as you can and
then
various the world changes and industrial
forces figure out that they can maximize
the feeling of sugar and fat
separate from any nutritive qualities
and then if you're if you're still like
stuck on that old heuristic and chasing
sugar and fat then
you know
you're kind of going to kind of be
screwed and i think that clarity can be
like cognitive sugar right
someone can aim to max out the feeling
of clarity what that looks like is a
conspiracy theory i mean it's
interesting that as you climb up the
ranks of scientology there's you know an
achievement unlocked which is going
clear that's literally what it's called
uh and
and that and you write that it can be
itself gamed right that search for
clarity and and you bring up a very
interesting distinction between
filter bubbles which we're all worried
about these days we're only listening to
people saying what we want to hear
versus echo chambers which are a little
bit more insidious than filter bubbles
i'll let you explain why right so this
is
so
so i can i can imagine listeners right
now being like
what does this person work on what
trust i think it's all
all connected really
i
i now sound like a conspiracy theorist
everything is connected
so uh
so
the
i got really interested
in
this stuff
when
i was watching
you know the rise of like
the alt-right and all the stuff and i
saw this research that said like oh
there are no
such things as echo chambers and i was
like what like look at the world yeah
what's going on and so i looked at the
data um
and it turned out that what they were
saying was that so
they were they're all these papers
showing that they're saying that there
were no such things as echo chambers and
the data they were saying was like oh if
you look at liberals they actually click
and their clicks
online they actually click through and
read fox news if you go conservative
they actually click through and read
like msnbc
and so
this idea that
you're not hearing the other side is
just
wrong right um and i remember thinking
that's not wait that's not that's not it
right and so i just been reading about
echo chambers
in the
philosophy literature for a really
strange reason um i've been really
interested this is this is where
actually this actually starts i'm really
interested in aesthetic echo chambers i
mean oh okay i i started researching on
based on things like
oh if all you've ever been exposed to is
classical music and everyone you trust
is a classical musician you're never
going to find a way into rap
right
um and it could just because like
i knew so
i was reading this stuff and i remember
seeing a definition of echo chamber in
the original definition of echo chamber
that comes from
this really important book from kathleen
hall jameson and
frank capela
the book is called echo chamber it
really pushes the word the into the
forefront of the conversation
is that an echo chamber is a system in
which people have been taught to
systematically distrust people on the
other side
it's a system of they don't quite say
that it's a cult but you know
they they they basically almost say this
is this book is an empirical analysis of
the world around rush limbaugh
um
and so it's that russian vows taught
people to systematically distrust and
dismiss people on the other side which
is different than not hearing them at
all yeah
so what happens is that later
especially eli priester writes this book
called the filter bubble in the filter
bubble the idea is oh everyone
in your facebook feed has your political
alignment so you don't you're never
exposed to argument to the other side i
think what happened is
right
in kind of the cultural consciousness
these two concepts collapsed and people
got stuck on the pariser concept you
don't hear people from the other side
and all this research i was saying
saying there was no such thing as echo
chambers all this was focused on the
hearing they were saying like look
fox news people actually know what the
liberal arguments are and i think this
confirms my experience like if you go on
like climate change denialist youtube
like they know what the arguments are
from like the standard arguments are for
the existence of climate change they
just have some reason to think that the
institutions are wholly corrupted yeah
right
so i think what's going on right now is
clearly an echo chamber effect in the
original sense
that it's a systematically disrupted
trust
rather than this kind of
filtering
effect
um where you don't hear the other side
and that's like we're talking about this
before already like
you a lot of a lot of
public policy figures are fixated on the
filter effect and thinking like oh we
just need to create these public spaces
where people will can meet each other
and talk to each other that's a standard
view and a lot of political philosophy
and public policy and i think that's not
going to work if trust has already been
systematically undermined it doesn't
matter if you meet and hear the other
side if you already have a prevailing
story that says
they're malicious
manipulative
evil people
and i presume this kind of attitude can
grow up maybe you know self-organized or
spontaneously but it can also be
uh engineered by the cult leaders right
you know you they can you can teach your
followers
traditional cult behavior that anyone of
course the cult will be criticized by
outsiders that's because you know
they're bad and and therefore when the
cult is criticized it's just getting a
prediction right it looks good
yeah that's so this is this is an effect
i
the clearest explanation of this effect
is from this philosopher named andre
bagby he has a paper called evidential
preemption and it's amazing it like it
really helped me understand what was
going on it's exactly the effect of like
if you if you're following rush limbaugh
and rush limbaugh says when you go when
you talk to those filthy liberals
they're going to say this and this and
this about me but don't try like you're
pre-prepared for it you have a you have
a pre-story ready you have already you
have a story already ready to dismiss it
and when you do dismiss it
um
when you do dismiss it
then
rush limbaugh's predictions will be
confirmed which if you're rational means
you should increase your trust in rush
limbo right
so it's i mean
the point here is
the point of a lot of this stuff is that
what looks to i mean
on the outside like totally rationality
is like a clever
rational
rationality manipulating construct and
that once you're in very irrational
behavior gets subverted well and the
connection back to the gamification
comes from this idea that clarity is
enhanced right that you've simplified
your life and made things a lot less uh
ambiguous and nuanced by just
having this
kind of simple world view where you can
dismiss a whole bunch of people
right yeah i know that the
one
i mean this is this weird way in which
in which i feel like the game experience
and the conspiracy theory echo chamber
experience are such
similar things in the game experience
you get to ignore
all these other moral constraints and
voices and considerations because you're
temporarily pursuing one simple goal
yeah and in the echo chamber experience
you get to ignore all these complex
moral considerations because you've
cut out of your trust world all these
voices that say something
morally distinctive
and you've centered yourself
on a world
of generally
a univocal moral attitude and causal
story about the world and if you do that
then you know you can feel really smug
and secure
um
and the world is all crisped up and
simple again yeah
um
and like that's that's
intoxicating i think that's i mean i
know it's intoxicating that's why i play
games yeah
but i mean that's that's a slightly
i don't know i i that's a slightly
depressing uh thing to say like
what is the way out of this because we
are all finite right and we do like
clarity and clarity is good if it's
aligned with the truth so uh you know
what's the what's the recipe what's the
what's the cure for this
so
i i can tell you the answer on an
individual level
i don't know the answer on the social
level so the i mean i don't know
i have some hints so here are some hints
um
one thought i've had is that
so the end of the games book tries to
say something like
um i try to say something like
the value of playfulness
so maria logones who's this amazing
feminist philosopher has this wonderful
paper about playfulness and world
traveling and what she says is
playfulness is the quality to transition
between different world perspectives
easily lightly to hold your perspective
lightly and slip between different ones
i think like playing a lot of games what
that is if you're doing it right is
slipping in between different valley
perspectives in and out in
and out
um
where
gamified worlds
and a lot of the echo chamber worlds are
ones in which you're dogmatically stuck
rigidly on one value perspective and
unable to adopt another so one thought
is
that the tendency to playfully explore
alternate perspectives
um
is one
is the kind of thing that could let you
see
your echo chamber from the outside right
how you instill that i don't know but
that's horrible here's another thing if
you're anxious about your own world so
go back to the sugar analogy so i think
at one point
in human evolution we could just eat as
much sugar and fat as we wanted now we
have to be aware that there are forces
that are trying to manipulate this
and we've developed i mean heuristics
can change right and i think some of us
i've had to develop the following
counter heuristic and that looks like
this
if i eat something i'm like oh that's so
yummy i just want to like cram it in my
mouth i immediately stopped and i'm like
okay wait stop
did someone manufacture this to make me
addicted to it
it's just too yummy let me look at the
nutritional information in the package
oh [ __ ]
maybe i can have a little but don't
evolve right so you have to be and i
think there's an equivalent of that
equivalent is is this moral view or
worldview too yummy
is it just
is it just like too is it just too
satisfying did someone make this
just for me and people in my cohort to
swallow down this is just a recipe for
sadness
no but really like i mean here here
this is by the way this doesn't mean
that never eat yummy foods or never
believe satisfying things it's just that
given that the world is full of forces
that have good incentives to create as
incredibly compellingly yummy
foods and belief systems as possible and
that they make so much money off of it
that your first reaction though should
be sufficient
like this is now how i like survive
i feel like
in the current media landscape right
like
the moment i read something like on
twitter i'm like oh i feel immediately
like oh wait wait wait wait hold on hold
on
is that actually right or does it just
feel good to believe it i mean i have to
do that i feel like i have to do this
constantly like but but this is like
this is yours like i feel like my
experience of living in the nutritional
world is the world's constantly being
like eat this it's [ __ ] delicious i'm
like oh hold on
wait a second right
i actually like depressing i like the
the yumminess uh analogy there the
cognitive yumminess because
we one of the values we have in certain
circles is skepticism right like you
know be skeptical of
these outrageous claims that you're
hearing and you don't want to be too
skeptical or you're let down some you
know rabbit hole not being able to
understand anything but but this is sort
of a
fine-tuning of that where you're saying
you know be skeptical of things that are
suspiciously yummy that you know like oh
that's a little bit too good to be true
and maybe not necessarily just be
skeptical of the substantive claim
but of why you like the claim so much i
mean this is definitely not a blanket
i mean
the thing is
you also get clarity and pleasure from
really getting at truths right and real
so like you can't throw all that stuff
away you just have to realize that the
signal has been it is amenable to you
know
perversion and misuse and be
i i'm starting to i think i can i can
like i develop like an internal feel for
it now what it feels like to like slip a
little because something is a little too
easy
um
but it's it's hard like and
like i said like this is a this is a
this is a personal
thing
that like i think a individual can try
to develop but as for like
getting
people on the large public scale to do
this i have no
idea well but maybe maybe to rephrase
your your implicit advice here um within
the game whatever game it is there's
clarity of values and goals and you're
you're struggling and that's that's
rewarding and you like this but they're
but that's also dangerous because
clarity can be a
chimera um but there's the meta game
there's the fact that you can play
different kinds of games right and that
kind of
training in playing different kinds of
games i think you put it uh at one point
like it's yoga for the self you're like
you're stretching yourself into
different
positions than it's usually used to and
that actually can you know help you
rebalance what it is you should be
paying attention to and believing
yeah i mean this is this is the idea of
playfulness right like
i mean this is not in some ways it's not
a new like there are plenty of accounts
of like this is so martha nussbaum
thinks like
a version of what martha newsman's view
is like this is what literature does you
occupy a different emotional perspective
yeah different
world
world views i mean i just think that
games offer you a similar version of
this but sure but
the
the
the transition between
if one of these traps works by getting
you to stop considering
the basis for these beliefs
then the way out is to
get out of the trap by reasoning for a
while from a different world view
um
and that
i mean
that would be great it's hard to do that
it's hard to put on different world
views as as like different sometimes i
think i mean this is this is this is
going to become the world's oldest
chestnut but sometimes i think like this
is what the [ __ ] humanities are for
like like
read some art like read some novels
[ __ ]
and um
i mean
if you want like the the background
paranoid
view
it's something like
the world has very good reasons to get
us to on board to like super simple
clear targets
um
and
when i
look at
universities cutting humanities programs
in favor of business goals in stem
because those are higher earning
jobs or lead to more clearly measurable
productivity i'm like i mean of course
like
reading weird subtle art and
experiencing weird alert
including games but also including
novels music and all this other stuff is
this stuff that might have clued you in
to like different value perspectives
other than make a lot of money and get a
good job
and of course
they're going to get cut out in a world
dominated by
hyper-simplified institutionalized
values
you know i i mean yeah i'm on your side
i'm a scientist myself some of my best
friends are scientists and engineers and
some of them are very very smart and yet
you constantly see this syndrome where
they fall
prey to just wanting a more simple and
clear picture of the world than actually
matches on to what the world is yeah
there's a i mean
there's
in many cases i think
that
i mean
aristotle
this this feels like a philosopher like
waxing it's always
aristotle
has
he has his dictum that every domain has
its own degree of clarity and we
shouldn't
expect more clarity than the domain can
provide and one of the suspicions i have
is that cert certain domains especially
the domains that science has a lot of
success with are the kinds of domains
that admit of extraordinary clarity
and other domains
like the domain of life value
and the domain
of
and
domains of like personal health and
fitness and aesthetic joy are not
domains admit of the same systemic
clarity when we demand them we start
hitting simplified targets and the
reason i think that there's there is a
base reason for this and i think that
this is okay i'm about to get out of my
pay grade a little bit but this is stuff
i've been thinking about a lot it's late
in the podcast go nuts
so if you read i've been reading so
michael strevins have you read michael
strevin's new book the knowledge machine
extraordinary um i love this book but i
think one of the things that makes clear
is that
scientific tools and in general the
tools of large-scale
observation information aggregation are
best at looking at qualities that are
invariant
across
time and space
so one of my favorite books in the
background here is theodore porter's
book trust in numbers which is a
historian he was really influenced by a
philosopher of science uh ian hacking oh
yeah and here's his view where he says
look there's a difference between
qualitative and quantitative data
qualitative data is really rich and
nuanced and subtle
but it's really context sensitive
it doesn't aggregate it doesn't travel
well
quantitative data
focuses on some invariant quality that
is doesn't change between context and so
everyone inputs the same quantity and
you can easily it's he says portable
across context and easy to aggregate so
an easy way for me to understand this is
think about the difference between
qualitative student evaluations of like
written work yeah and
a quantified letter grade the
qualitative information is so much so
much useful has all the stuff in it but
i can't like people outside of my little
discipline can't interpret it and it
isn't aggregatable so instead we produce
this thing this like standardized
ranking that suppresses all this data
and that aggregates easily and travels
well so
um
that's
that's uh that's porter's view and you
can add this to james scott view so do
you have you read james scott seeing
like a state no i don't think so it's
one of the most amazing books to have
come out in the last few decades and
scott basically picks up on this and
says
look what you should think is that
large-scale institutions can only see
the parts of the world
that are in that are in that are
processable by large-scale bureaucratic
machines which are
quantified data they can't register the
parts so think about this a large scale
school district or an educational
bureaucracy
can't register individual student
evaluation data they can only register
aggregateable data like gpa um so says
scott the world large-scale institutions
have a reason to remake the world along
lines that are more regular so that they
can be legible to the institution and
actable on by the institution anyway so
i've gone too far so to sum up um
if you buy the story and you buy like
i think a coherent the kind of current
view of what
of science as good as creating
standardized data then what you should
think is that the methods of science are
really good at looking at things that
are naturally invariant
across people
like i don't know the way our immune
systems work but we should be less good
at looking at things that vary radically
between people and are highly
personalized like
what makes you joy joyous what makes you
happy what makes you satisfied and that
if you
approach it using the methodology then
it'll only be able to track features
that are standardized across people so
there's actually interesting work here
in the philosophy of well-being um but
one thought is that people are looking
for a measure of well-being that's like
and that might not exist that might not
be the kind of thing that exists it
admits a standardization and if you look
for that
then you're going to get the world of
fitbit
that's sorry that's my like massively
paranoid
pessimistic world view well and uh and
that's a it's a good place to wind up
but i think the real lesson here that
i've learned is that i would make a
terrible cult leader i'm i'm not i have
this following on the podcast that i'm
just not using it correctly to instill a
false sense of clarity among my
listeners maybe i should start doing
that
yeah you should definitely do that i
mean i
figure out how you do that i
i actually one of the things i think
that's really fun to do
is to game out exactly how you would
instill a false sense of clarity and a
bunch of people yeah look at the system
you create and then
ask yourself how much that's like
certain real world belief systems that
are circulating
that it's a very scary scary game you
have just suggested to us but uh we can
all go contemplate it at home so teen
wen thanks very very much that for being
on the mindscape podcast thank you so
much for having me
[Music]
you